[Musique]
le fil conducteur de mon exposé c'est de
pouvoir de la passion ou encore le
miracle de l'engagement
vous allez vous rendre compte que tout
ce que nous faisons avec la scion nous
le faisons sans nous rendre compte des
efforts et les investissements de
l'énergie que nous avons gâché pour
investir à un paiement vous implémentez
notation alors le miracle de
l'engagement
vous allez vous rendre également dans
mon propos il faut que j'ai depuis la
décision j'ai eu la passion de ce que je
voulais devenir dans la vie alors je me
suis engagé et une porte c'est toujours
pratiquement sans voix sur 100 il
fonctionne toujours ouverte lorsque j'ai
voulu interpréter un objectif clé à des
moments clés de maintenir le pouvoir de
la passion est inspirée des ouvrages le
pouvoir de la confiance en soi des
bryans précis en fait la confiance en
soi lorsqu'on a ce pouvoir de ce qu'on
est passionné la confiance en soi
viennent tout se met parfois de façon
claire et conscience si vous pouvez
m'aider un peu voyez vous cette passion
des nasses de lessive lorsque je suis
entré j'ai dit on a été les témoins
cette histoire me suis jusqu'ici voix
éthérée après les meilleurs écrits des
doigts dans le nez mais j'arrive dans
les meilleures universités du cameroun à
l'écho en 1985 en voix éthérée donc je
ne suis pas si je tiens à lui dis parce
que je suis né d'une famille
monoparentale
donc ma mère se mêlaient de père que je
n'ai évidemment pas pour nous on nous
parle d'elle que je n'ai pas retenu a
été exécuté pendant les années l'élan de
au lendemain de l'indépendance comme aux
hommes en 1965
grande dame qui est né en 1957 en 1965
et qui a été élevé par sa mère a été
élevée par une maman qui n'avait pas une
profession qui n'avait pas de nom
d'ailleurs thomas tente comme mon père à
l'époque elle est en cuivre ou tués dans
ce que nous avons appelé l'écran de
s'oublier de l'histoire alors soulevé un
peu sur le fil conducteur les grands
oubliés de l'histoire pourquoi parce que
l'histoire ne les a pas retenus
l'histoire ne les a pas commémorer
l'histoire ne les met pas en avant pour
stimuler est activée elle se vouloir et
se faire dans la vie d'autres femmes qui
ont qu'une fait quelque chose qui ont pu
mettre montre déjà les dix jours en tire
aujourd'hui des niveaux qui sont arrivés
à ce stade de la société je voudrais que
ma priorité
donc elle me je suis né dans annuels et
cette sentinelle tout au tout que
monsieur mamère à l'église catholique où
je suis baptisée à l'âge de 12 ans est à
12 ans je sais que lorsque dieu dit lui
plus personne ne peut changer voilà je
veux inculquer en vous certaines valeurs
en fait lorsqu'on ne peut compter que
sur dieu
on est avec des valeurs les valeurs
d'intégrité de pardonner de rigueur
délicat parfois maladie parce que ceux
qui ne vous convient pas fini ce mardi
mais selon les méchantes ont travaillé
nuit et jour et le vois bien parce
qu'elle même n'a pas pris en trop me est
ce le violon de l'école à 18 ans et doit
étudier jusqu'à une heure du matin
seraient atteintes leur index un moment
avant d'aller à l'école sur près de 4 km
le bou arrivé à maturité à 10 ans plus
tard voilà comment j'évolue
et comment donc marcher aventure au
milieu de leur sécurité maison de
l'environnement
des zones avec le h évidemment c'est pas
tout le monde qui veut vous apportiez
dans les objectifs je ne suis pas des
autres cette nature et cette saison avec
le hbh hostilités de l'environnement en
sachant que finalement seul nom que le
tempérament naturel est notre premier
ennemi notre tempérament cette fois
c'est comment nous réagissons aux
événements c'est au nom nous réagissons
même avec le venue dans le monde
dans cet environnement hostile comme
nouvelle c'est comment nous réagissons
ni même avec nos passions avec mon désir
avec jallet dit avec nos objectifs avec
nos plans de vie alors tout n'était pas
sur un plateau données sur un plateau en
or
non que j'aie des indécis qui pourrait
témoigner de la témérité qui même si
c'est les téméraires le grand frère ou
soeur jean emmanuel pondi la seconde vie
dans la prise de conscience des réalités
qui nous environne est le commencement
de notre plan de vie la prise de
conscience
la prise de conscience est le
commencement de cette décision de
changer son environnement de bousculer
tous redoutent soit je voyais cet
environnement et je disais mon dieu
pourquoi suis né à newburgh où je suis
né dans une telle précarité dans cette
étude y est il faut que je fasse le
droit pour changer cette ville il faut
que je fasse de moi pour aller contre
les inégalités je suis allergique
l'asthme allergique à la justice si vous
voulez me donner du cran jeudi de la
provence où voulait que j'avance
alors mettez vilain geste est devant moi
mais témoin devant des défis mais si ça
devient comme si vous avez je ne sais
pas vous avais tu ne parles pas elle
vous allez pour ainsi dire comprendre
quel est mon cas
moi ma rage de transformer les droits
des femmes aux communes et nous avons
donc celui-ci - décidé de faire de loi
et je vous dirais tu es la place de
premier j'avais décidé de l'appeler
madame hillary clinton est depuis
l'assemblée y est la place des trucs et
elle était professeur de loi à l'inversé
de new york
j'ai décidé voyez vous un [ __ ] j'ai
décidé et j'aime marcher avec ce film
lorsque l'année où j'ai mon bac j'ai un
un bar secrétariat technique on oublie
des vestes et des garmin et aux marchés
ce n'était pas le cas une porte s'ouvre
toujours pour quiconque est engagée qui
marche avec ses passions
cette porte saint-michel et voilà que
avec un berger j'arrive à faire la loi
et voilà qu'avec un marché je suis
enseignant de droit des affaires depuis
25 ans voilà qu'avec un marché je fais
des choses comme ida chafaï dit je ne
suis pas né pour être secrétaire mais je
n'ai pas adoubé liste de mon état donc
voilà et la passion de l'inculpation
portage et l'engagement je vois cette
émission déjà contaminé ici dans des
petites soeurs qui n'ont pas cédé un
petit seul non pas ce marché ne s'est
pas enclenché
n'est ce pas que j'ai que j'ai traîné
elles ont tout je peux dire que y'en a
qui vont sortir ici et me dit mais
qu'est ce que chacun d'eux j'ai déjà son
potentiel
j'ai déjà tout j'ai déjà cet
environnement là je peux m'appuyer pour
évoluer
j'ai perdu énormément de temps et le but
de mon rétro des ajustements d'amener
celles qui sont dans cette salle qui
croit qu'il faut encore un décret voté
un wagon à syndication de jean pierre
moga
parce que le potentiel est naturelle le
potentiel est in hairy suffit de cliquer
dessus
une morte sous
le chantier limitée des opportunités que
nous offrait la vie lorsque nous
travaillons à des créations jaurès et
des mauvaises politiques pouvaient
dérouler pour que les gens voient
comment en 2009 en mâchant avait cette
passion j'ai remporté une madame il
avait dit qu'il allait présenter des
tranchées pendant trois semaines j'ai
fait cette formation en belgique envoyé
par l'ambassade des états unis
ensuite en 2007 chez ton plaisant
françois hollande l'autre sont passables
son voyage officiel au cameroun lors de
son voyage officiel au tapis nous
l'avons rencontré voilà une de vos
passions mais devient parti de rien en
2012 déjà
voilà leur fond qui est professeur et au
village on dit mais elle est bien dans
celle d'un financement monoparentales si
la roma n'a pas pu évoluer et le et le
vivre ce que le pen n'a pas pu faire et
ce que l'armée n'a pas pu faire elle va
faire tout ceci et on en venir au
village en 2013 et voilà la rencontre
avec le christ nous a su j'ai envie
quand je parle de ça avec passion avec
tout mon coeur avec tout mon aise avec
ce que j'aime le plus absolu
les + 2 dans la dignité humaine j'ai
envie de prendre sa première fille et de
thil à chacune des familles s'y met à
prendre ceci fait comme moi fait que je
me dis c'est d'expérience sait
d'expérience que je parle et une porte
de cette mission des fêtes lorsque vous
n'êtes pas conscient d'où vous partez
que vous voulez réaliser
même les gens timides et vous
c'est devant que je vous assure elles
vont filer complètement et vous ne
laissez ce n'est pas parce que vous
marchez sa mission le marché s'inquiète
la dernière c'est parce que je voulais
donc mots clés pour tout ceci vous
stimulez votre engagement
c'est ça depuis je suis bien et ça y est
gravement malade et moins 188 congrès
vous même et militante cesser d'enrichir
mon militantisme il suffit d'échanger
avec ceux qui ont pris l'engagement
justement que se conformer à ces normes
sociales se marier en thème des libertés
j'ai dit que pour lui c'est marine
j'étais bien que ce synode a été l
notables comme qui pourrait le voir dans
la vie ceci que je voudrais dire que
dans l'immense océan des coupes des lits
des opportunités éliminer une toque
souffre du genou pour une femme engagée
alors en cache toi et fait le premier
pas l'univers fera le reste